sandra did you ever think that you'd be
talking about channing tatum's butt so
much in your entire life well i mean
after every magic mic everyone's talking
about channing tatum's butt so i just i
just got on the bandwagon the butt wagon
[Music]
the butt wagon i am the funniest person
i know
okay i like that one all right on the
butt wagon on the butt wagon i enjoyed
your book about the lost city and i
believe you're the one who could help me
find its treasure
i have to respectfully decline i'm
afraid i must insist
well congratulations on this film again
obviously more and more people are
starting to see it in different cities
what has it been like for you guys to
hear the reactions because i think y'all
have a hit on your hands that's cool i
mean i i don't know what you do i
genuinely try and stay away from that
i hear a bit of like second-hand
reaction which is always very nice but
there is some there's something
satisfying about like it being out there
now and people getting to you know i
feel like i've been talking about this
film like really guys i've done a film
with sandra bullock and channing tatum
for a while so it's nice to have proof
out there in the world i i try not to i
try to just when you're in a press
junket it's either one way or the other
either you walk into the room and
they're like
so the reviews aren't great uh but let's
just let's just go give it our best okay
so i i try to just go into a
a situation like this make just make
some memories
have some laughs tell some jokes and
just go about your business and but look
it's it's um i don't know what to say i
i just
i want a comedy i want to laugh
i want nice people to work with
uh i know how lucky we are you know in
in what we get to do even if this film
was a bomb i still uh would be insanely
grateful
for the time that we had and what we get
to do totally
listen loretta we need you to promote
your new book on the lost city you can't
spend your life in the bathtub during
chardonnay with eyes
ladies and gentlemen the world's sexiest
cover model dash mcmahon
you do know you're not dash right dash
is a character i made up that's like oh
my god
oh crap you mentioned being with the
nice people that you got to work with
obviously being in the middle of the
dominican republic jungle with this cast
and crew who are such an incredible
bunch what stands out from that time
that chapter in your lives as a
memorable moment i mean just it was
you know how
how hard everyone worked i mean to bring
this film to life i mean and also there
was one moment which you rarely get on a
set where they about sort of a month
into shooting they played a little reel
of like the stuff we'd shot already on
set for the cast and crew to sort of see
and that was an amazing moment of going
like you could feel like the excitement
instead of like oh we're making a really
cool movie guys this looks great like
that was a very you know and then that
inspires you to work even harder for the
rest of it yeah i think as you say in
the dominican republic is is that people
don't realize
you know when we put the movie out there
it's just what's on the screen but we
could not have done
any of what we did without the 450
people of the dominican republic who
safely got us there
and home during a pandemic an epidemic i
would go back to the dominican republic
and film
any time that they would allow me back
and that's what i think is the most
memorable thing for me are the
extraordinary and loving people of the
dominican republic who just
rolled out a red carpet for us and and
allowed us to to do what we did this is
not a romance novel jungles eat people
like us what is that get it off
i can feel
holy mother of god you guys mentioned
how hard you worked in the jungle and
sandra i know for you they really put
you through it snakes leeches being in a
jungle with fields we're at our best i
think as actors when we are between a
rock and a hard place if things are too
easy you don't get to react to it so
you know it's funnier when you see
someone fall down a set of stairs than
when you see someone navigate them
successfully and and uh if we needed to
fall down a couple sets of stairs to
make you laugh then then then we were
gonna fall was there anything that you
were particularly
maybe not as 100 thrilled about doing or
did you see everything as an opportunity
to just do something new
i mean i didn't have to do anything that
hard i mean you know there was nothing
really stunty in there for me i was
never in like the sort of uncomfortable
situations that these guys you were in
well-fitting suits you had to keep them
clean i had to keep them playing that
was a concern i mean the only yeah there
were a couple of really cool bugs that i
saw that were crazy on the final days in
the caves there was like a spider the
size of that like a purple tarantula
yeah the size of your hand and it was
that was that was pretty cool but no i i
had a much
comparatively nicer time than almost
everyone else on the shoot i mean how
many people can say they've gotten
pelted by a charcuterie board
well
when when well in college
right i mean so what was fun about this
film was taking real life and then
putting it into
moments
in this film like they like in
retrospect i go oh that was based on
this moment that was based on this
moment wait is the choco tree based on
something no it's just i love cheese
okay sorry the writer and i love cheese
and there's been some lonely nights in
the bathtub with a charcuterie plate and
a glass of wine i'm not i'm not
embarrassed about that no suggestion no
art imitating life
yes
make fun of me it's okay
i love it now obviously sandra you've
been a part of so many iconic movie
moments over the years in your career
like proposing in the middle of the
street to ryan reynolds in the proposal
driving a bus in speed the tripping
scene in miss congeniality how do you
think getting pushed in a wheelbarrow by
brad pitt and channing tatum ranks
amongst those because that was the
moment when we were all watching the
theater that it was just non-stop
laughter it seemed like that was the
moment it was a moment that
literally we didn't know it was going to
be that it's you know everything had to
happen
at once
that was we only did that shot in one
take we didn't know how big the
explosion was going to be we didn't
realize that the st the stunt guys and
the effects guys were saying now if the
cars blow the opposite direction in the
direction of sandy channing and brad we
need everyone i'm like i'm the one
that's zip tied to the chair
but um it all it's like you know a lot
of it is preparation preparation
preparation and then a whole lot of luck
who knew channing would prance like you
know a little gazelle
and we didn't know that brad was going
to flip the hair i didn't know it was
going to be so loud wait he just did
that hair flip he did the hair flip he's
good he's so good
just a lot of things had to come
together and thankfully they did as you
mentioned the hair flip what was the wig
budget like a part of this film between
channing and brad
well the you know it's all about hair i
mean look at daniel's wicked good cut i
mean that was a cultivated cut that was
i was a little obsessive like we'd be on
set and i'd be like let me just get that
it's great it's just yeah i think i
think hair is important in comedy
hair today gone tomorrow i mean and
channing's
and uh
channing did turn into a different
person in the wig as well it was like he
would walk slightly differently and he
really like the spirit of fabio just
kind of he made us all a little
uncomfortable that day i didn't like him
as much as i do without the weight
really something about him was like
it just was a little gross
you